ah crap I can do the thing oh shut up
I don't know what this is yes I do it's
SCP Observer now this is a game that
said it was based on sap Containment
Breach but it's not the same gameplay I
think that this might just maybe be
something like observation Duty
never mind is it like Five Nights at
Freddy's oh my God it is
is it scp-079 an xcd sourcerer
microcomputer oh I know that one uh try
to take over the monitors okay
it's a 5 Nights at Freddy's I don't want
to say that right off the bat because I
don't know that for sure
oh my God
it even looks like us if you can never
breach
use the task list on the main control
panel to perform all maintenance tasks I
don't know if I wanna
I don't know if I wanna
the security room is equipped with
servers security monitors and a
generator and access to the facility's
camera systems it is designed to ensure
the safety of security guards and
researchers during containment breaches
maintain camera freed in case a
val-function surface can cause
electrical Sparks must be manually
repaired can be open or closed using the
corresponding levers on the right
control panel activated used in
corresponding keypads on the right
control panel monitor the area directly
in front of the security room which may
be a blind spot security camera system
you use the keyboard on the center or
right control panel to access the
facility's camera system displays all
available rooms highlighted Rooms To
indicate ongoing activity
allows remote control oh man there's a
lot of stuff I don't know uh I'm sure
I'll get to that soon attention
security Chief Franklin please report to
containment chamber 1 7 3 immediately
that's probably fine I don't think
that's going to be any bit of a issue
okay check generator status turn off all
monitors that display a connection lost
screen okey dokey then
uh
uh right
all right that was easy so check the
generator status
all right where's the generator
and properly that's a fuse box more than
a generator
this River's now working okey dokey
verify the functionality of the front
security monitors okay I think it was
okay
well
oh
ah
oh boy
oh
there
control system the door isn't responding
to any of our attempts to close it so
please maintain direct eye contact with
SCP-173 and
wait what the [__]
well that's a problem wait I have a
blink beater wait a minute wait a minute
I thought I was just going to be
observing
don't be afraid
this is a dream
the last dream you may ever have well
for nightmares are coming
coming oh
good it is
why is no one done this idea already
what I literally missed those what did
you say what did you say to me oh no
wait I missed it uh talk to me again
hold on
hey man oh [__]
ah
fascinating oh is that the mask no
that's the
that's the creation machine
isn't it
are they coming for me
uh
hi okay I think I'm getting the layout
that's a good thing I think
oh
that's useful okay oh this is robust
hey wait a minute hey can you keep that
close
hmm
well
um
oh wait a minute hey okay let's stop
uh
boy the blink is really blonking um
I only have 65 3 power generated
oh God
what do you mean man my blinks are so
blonky okay so when I'm not using the
camera system I gotta turn it off or
else I'm not going to be able to have
any power left
I I don't think he's gonna let me keep
that closed
you turn it off
okay
three percent power great what is usage
two
hey
no no no no
okay
oh
why I don't like it I'm assuming that
nothing is going to be coming from the
East door because scenario one seems to
suggest that there's only going to be
softly shimmy oh wait a minute wait a
minute what do I do about that wait what
wait a minute wait stop
whoa
what
which way did you go
oh well that's fine wait a minute wait a
minute where are you going
wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute I don't come
any closer oh boy
um uh
oh hey what's up I gotta go get power do
I have time for that
I definitely do I'm gonna go rep out
oh God uh three percent
oh this dick is oh what is that about
what are you doing here get out of here
get out of here oh you're gonna make me
miss my mark on the I didn't turn it off
oh
hey oh why what
hold on
shut up
did I zap him good I zapped him good oh
what's working I don't know
where did you go oh over here
ah perfect I'm the best
um did he get zapped uh because usually
when I got zapped in the game don't even
try it watch this
yeah
that's what you get yeah you go back
yeah you go back it's not for you
oh [__]
don't do it
don't
I am so scared I'm looking away ah
King away
I'm looking away turning it off
two hours left I'm gonna die oh why you
guys be standing there
supremely inconvenient for me
very inconvenient I need power oh don't
go now whatever you do don't go right
now right now is the worst time for you
to go
terrible time for you to go oh terrible
time for me to run out of Sprint
oh God
wait a minute
wait it's not even on
wait I don't need that on
wait then what does that do wait I'm
confused
that might be a bug
what what are we doing what you were
doing something
what are you doing
oh [__] ah Westgate oh
take that I'm out of power oh was that
even the right gate west east west west
oh no
do it
Legacy input Freddy uh doing his
right in that hallway
[Music]
[Applause]
glad that's over
huh
wait a minute
so can I access this oh no oh
well what I what
what am I supposed to do about that
I might know you about that dear well
oh
sir
oh that's great
oh that's
spooky
huh
oh
what is that what is that
what is that I need power so what is the
benefit of this
ah is that like
oh that's probably like right outside
the door or something maybe oh where did
you go
where did you go
oh [__]
oh shoot oh shoot
oh
problem
oh come on
I just rubbed my
feet on the floor
um Get Wrecked
Get Wrecked I'm going to get wrecked I
don't know where this thing went it was
in the window there and it's not there
anymore
and that's a problem what
oh
what no no
no
oh you [__]
don't do it don't do it
do it don't do it don't don't do it
don't do it don't who are you
hi
how are you are you normal can you come
find me cause I ain't feeling good
oh crap
fine
we're so fine
you know I survived SCP Containment
Breach without even having a safe room
so uh
what do you think about that
nothing didn't think so you're too
afraid
stop it
stop it get some help
three hours left I'm doing a lot better
on power than I was last time oh [__] oh
[__] wait a minute don't do it
yeah that's right you better back off
I think he was I think he was West or
but I don't know
I don't know
hello come find me I don't know where
dude man is
because you like right outside that
would be very unfortunate for me
I'll be like super unfortunate
I can keep these doors closed for a
while that's very nice
oh what do you mean
oh okay you weren't doing it okay
so was that the door outside my chamber
I have a feeling that he's in the west
because if I look at the map left it
this is West right so he's not in the
bright
because that wouldn't make any sense so
I could open the right one the only
thing I don't know is where the hell
that other thing went
so I should be able to
stop it I don't have enough power for
that I should be able to open the East
one that's my conclusion
I'm opening it because it doesn't matter
because I didn't need to close that one
in the first place
right
stop it
two hours left
don't see a reason that I would need to
urgently close the other side oh
you all right bud
I hear that
I like hear the doors opening and
closing around me can I go out into the
facility is this something that I could
do oh God the power oh [__]
don't do it
I'm so close
I'm gonna make it oh 17 seconds
three percent okay I think I'm gonna
make it I'm definitely gonna make it
Hondo P gonna make it
all three protect oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank goodness
what can I do what am I gonna do when
there's three different zones
what do you expect me to do oh one seven
three no oh is there anybody else that
can help me wait a minute
start camera scan what do you mean what
does that mean
what do you mean
stop it get some help all right so long
as I'm on top of those dudes he just
came back you [__]
yeah wait what does this do again I I
don't even remember
well that seems Andy this is another way
to get cameras oh I didn't know that oh
hey dude
yeah you're the Survivor good luck
okay ah
well
all right then
does that mean radical Larry is out and
about
oh God that would have been good to get
to a moment before
oh
[Music]
that's so unfair why would you do that
why would you do that why would you do
that can I leave can I go
I would like to go
oh boy
oh well that's a problem ew what are you
what are you you're awful I hate you
oh God no
you're still there
and again I don't know what what does
scammer scan do
oh
ah
oh shoot
well that's uh bad
um uh uh oh
okay oh dog what do dogs
best
you thought you had me but turns out
you're dumb why is two power beings I
said door idiot Try It You'll never get
in
stupid
what are you thinking
boy I wish you were
not there
okay
oh crap wait hold on a second
ah crap
crap
well that's an unreasonably stressful
environment to work in I'm gonna make a
complaint with OSHA and I will make sure
to get this place shut down
[Music]
I'm gonna Sue uh so thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to play
this is free like a lot of SCP games are
it's free and it's actually quite well
made I like it very faithful to the
original SCP Containment Breach uh let
me know what you thought comments below
as always
I'll see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
foreign